[Music]
well good evening welcome members
officers and those members of the public
that have joining us this evening for
this extraordinary full council meeting
on the 8th of 8th of
august moving into the
agenda item one apologies for absence
thank you chair
pencil hurley councillor craigie
councillor bright councillor manly
chancellor jones councillor locke
councillor ford
councillor cotton hunting councillor
brenton and councillor langford
thank you sandra
item two public contributions i
understand we have no public speakers
tonight
so we'll move on to item three
declarations of interest
i'm sure you know by known members the
procedure for declaring an interest
item four agreement gender items part
one and part two can have a proposal
assignment
counselor james
part one
and the second item in part two
and the second about
thank you
item five on the agenda is to consider
correspondence and i've brought forward
especially by the chair
i haven't i personally have none but i i
know the council leader pence james but
that makes sense
just like the brief segment um it's not
a question anyway thanks for the brief
statement
and it follows on from the article in
the journal and done live about planning
application in weekly
um i have went to the papers with my
concern that the way it was worded was
could do represent reputational damage
to the council it also undermines our
officers
we have brought to
um
say we it's okay myself with virtue with
jeffrey cox and we've arranged to meet
him which is probably going to be late
in september that's who it is he won't
do it and i understand 10 miles from
north devon has also wrote with his
concerns about the
how we're dealing with the five-year
land supply in the planet and so it's
not a
planning specific it's the points in
general so i'd just like to write that
so if you do see an article i don't know
where they will publish it but i will be
doing a statement in the paper just to
query
some of the things they said
thank you
good morning
uh item six uh on the agenda it's a
standards hearing on the fourth of
august and the head of legal and
governance is gonna present with them
[Music]
um good evening councillors
so this matter was originally presented
to paul council in january this year
um following a recommendation from
standards from the standards committee
um there was a standard hearing
for those who aren't aware
and in summary the standards committee
found that councillor ford had reached
the code of conduct for the following
reasons he'd failed to treat others with
respect including members officers of
the council and other people they
haven't come into con that you come into
contact with
um not to act in a way which could
reasonably be regarded as bringing
either their office or a member of the
council into disrepute
not to bully or intimidate or attempt to
bully or intimidate any person
and not to use the resources of the
council for purposes which conflict with
the council's requirement or political
or personal purposes
and to treat everyone equally
impartially and fairly represent the
residents of the whole of the council
area
so the matter was referred um to full
council
um standards had originally made the
resolution that councillor ford should
write um written apologies to all the
complainants where their complaints are
upheld
and to recommend that paul council
exclude councillor ford from the
council's offices
or other premises with the exception of
attending for full council
and when it was referred to full council
full council um
in addition
stated that his torridge district
council email address should be
removed with a requirement that that
be reviewed um after six months now
that's the purposes of bringing the
report back today we're a little bit
late but we
uh there was a northern town council
election so we're under herder
so the purpose of today's report is for
members to consider whether to continue
those sanctions i.e continue with the
removal of the torres district council
email address and continue with his
exclusion
from the council offices
except
with prior arrangements with the chief
executive
i'm just going to hand over to lolita
who wants to say a couple of words
thank you uh
um
great sadness i actually we have to do
this again i genuinely believe that
an awful lot of time
is wasted on it um but cancer fall i
start complied with the original um
requests for what he does in fact and
still continue to descend the sea
and so i will compose the recommendation
but we continue to remove his email
address and he knows use another one
which we don't know
you know so the one industry which still
comes through
um that members decide whether we
continue to exclude them from the
council with offices or other premises
with the exception of the meeting rooms
a secondary attendance with council
committee and sub-committee meetings
and can support only to attend the
offices
on other occasions where they can hire
arrangements with achievements there and
i would suggest that we do that um until
the end of
this coming council
[Music]
very sorry woman's position
the counselor who fails
there's no way to deliver the sanctions
and we're so close to the end of this
plan as a recommendation
sure just to follow on what uh counselor
laws has just said it's not only that he
continues to fail to comply with what we
have previously required to do to
apologize but indeed the trail of abuse
of
members elected members and officers
continues unabated
and i mean i and he authorized me to say
he's not here tonight but
what hope have we got of attracting more
younger counselors when they are
subjected to emails
recently from councillor ford to
councillor jones that said you are a
boring insignificant
full stop
now that email rightly has been um sent
to the monitoring officer and referred
to the standards committee as well but
it it's never-ending so it's not just
the line that we put in the sand it
continues and i can't see that there's
nothing democratic in this we're not
reducing anybody's freedom of speech
this is just abuse that goes on and on
and shouldn't be tolerated
well i don't think we need to
continually debate the almost score with
regard to this very sad incident it's
been revolted by council james secondary
country law and i have a short hands in
support of that washington
looks unanimously
are the abstentions
[Music]
item seven on the agenda is an exclusion
of the public as the remainder of the
meeting contains example confidential
information
that's